oui êtes vous oui ou non
nelson monfort
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous parlez
[Musique]
en 1995 la reine d'angleterre recevait
les cheveux les à l'ancien président
talent pour le résident polonais de
l'époque et vous allez croire ou pas
cette histoire ce qui est histoire est
vraie un moment donné l'un des chevaux
l'achat la chapelle aussi au 6e rang que
bruyant et la reine dit à alès va les as
rome sosa oui ce sous-entendu excuses le
chien avec son accent un peu polonais
anglais au deuxième match fat32 rage
je pensais que c'était le cheval 20
personnes vous zappez apprendra alors
vous appelez-vous oui c'était parce
qu'avec mon coeur tu sais c'est pas trop
mon fort si je peux dire pour faire
plaisir à l'aviron
on est quel jour aujourd'hui en principe
le 12 mars le 12 mars qu'est ce que
c'est que le 12 mars et là c'est une
surprise on ne sait pas l'anniversaire
de mon agent c'est juste
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez allez j'y vois là pas pour moi
même sort que les balkans